seconds did you ever think you would
make it I feel I'm so I tet Victory I
know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value taming giving values
this world of entrepreneurs we get no
value to ha run homie look what I become
I'm I'm the
one so uh folks we're learning uh
different languages today uh uh from a
very uh renowned heart surgeon uh who
somehow became uh decided to uh uh
change can you imagine your heart
surgeon okay that's what you're doing
for a living okay and all of a sudden
one day you're inspired to want to be a
comedian okay because you want watch a
guy named John Stewart which we talked
about yesterday M he just recently chose
to part ways with apple over them not
letting them do shows on AI in China and
so you man I can just visualize you as a
heart surgeon in the middle of a heart
surgery he's telling all the nurses
jokes and oh this one we messed up oops
this is this one's gone it's not going
to work any you don't need this do you
it's just your heart I want to be a
comedian so heart surgeon you would
assume you're doing well for yourself
you're making money you got respect
you've gone to school then you take the
risk to go be a comedian you don't just
become a regular comedian a third of
your country is listening to you got 40
million give or take weekly listeners to
your show and then you're being invited
all over the place and recently some of
you may recognize him because of the
podcast or the show that he did with uh
Pierce Morgan which the angle he took
was very different satire comedy it
almost confus pierce it was so confusing
that pierce had to get on a plane to go
to La at the comedy club to interview
him and it was a great uh uh encounter
back and forth uh gave a different
perspective to everybody but today we
have in the flesh Bassam ysep how are
you sir
hello from the other
side can you hear I'm a little bit under
the influence yeah and the influence
meaning that I'm still under heavy pain
medication how long did you you you
you've been traveling 48 hours so so
just in 5 days 5 days in 5 days I I took
the plane from La yeah to Dubai for 48
48 hours and then I went from Dubai to
Boston for 36 hours for another shows in
Arabic and K then went from Boston to
Dubai again for another oh my God and
then that was less than 24 hours and
then I took the flight from Dubai to
Miami and just landed yesterday oh my
God yeah and then you're performing and
I'm performing tonight tonight and
tomorrow and after tomorrow and after
tomorrow yeah Friday Saturday Sunday at
the mayami
improve so you're fired up is what
you're saying you're I am so excited but
I cannot hide it yeah it's it's very I
got a question for you I mean seriously
like before we we got a lot of things
we're going to get into I got I want
your thoughts on a lot of different
stories and you know uh whether it's
some current events your background
politics we'll talk Israel we'll talk
Palestine we'll talk Egypt we'll talk
all that stuff what was the turning
point for you like did did people always
know you were funny like when I when I
talk to a comedian I say at what point
did you know you were funny you know
well when I was 10 years old my dad
would tell me hey you know go out there
and perform and make everybody laugh and
all my dad's friends like Vinnie my
dad's friends would watch me and I like
oh my God this kid's so funny oh when I
was our life was so hard and you know it
was all about you know comedy was the
what you know kind of lower the
temperature for me where I could use it
and you know laughter and all this stuff
if you're a surgeon you went to school
10 to 12 years to be a surgeon right so
at what point did you know you were
funny and you may want to consider a
career in comedy I never thought that I
was funnier than usual there was
actually people in my school that were
funnier they're the one who are much
cooler with the girls I never had a
girlfriend so I was like an okay guy you
never had a girlfriend I never had a
girlfriend with those eyes you never had
a girlriend never never because I
couldn't know how to speak to women I uh
till so so when I finished my primary
school the the elementary school my
parents took me took me into a much
Richer School much more expensive school
and my parents were uh University
professors and judges so they only like
they were government employees so they
can kind of scrapped in order to push me
to that to that was the best school in
in town which is great but the problem
is you end up with all of the rich kids
so you feel that you're less you feel
you're not like that so people didn't
mind me they were not mean to me or
anything but I wasn't boyfriend material
I played Sports very well and I was a
nerd that's so I was like a typical nerd
who like glasses and nobody wants to
talk to him but i w i i wasn't cool I
was one of the cool kids with the with
all of experiences and the money and
then when I finished medical when I
finished the school I went to the
medical school now medical medical
school there are Arab uh notab um
government so everybody from all of the
country comes in all of the people who
go to the free schools and these are
these people are they like nerds Big
Time nerd so I come in I am from the
rich school now I am the I'm the the
soft kid from the kid school you're now
the elite yeah now I'm the elite and
then I uh so I I always felt that I'm
out of place I never felt that I belong
to anybody and uh whether or not you're
funny or not well there's other doctors
who are funny people make fun in the
operating room but the fact that
actually you do a show that was not even
there so it just took took me like three
four YouTube videos that I produced it
put it online didn't think about it at
all and it just like blew up
wait but you have to know like before
you've had glimpses of you make people
laugh and get a reaction no like you you
know how a girl knows she's beautiful I
don't know what it is to be a beautiful
girl but I would assume this girl at 16
17 18 19 20 years old she's like why are
grown men checking me out why is it that
they look at me the way they do or a man
that all of a sudden you see how a woman
looks at you you're like you can read a
lot when you see someone's eyes right
you never had a glimpse of people
watching you and saying this guy is
super funny and likeable I I had people
think that I'm funny and people think
that I'm not it's just like I was like
I'm not I was not out out of the range
like I thought this guy was supposed to
be a funny guy Pat I'm out here no no
what for me what I mean by this is Wild
is when the camera's on and you're
performing like you've been doing this
your entire life you know you've been
you've been making people laugh and
think and satire you've been doing that
for a long time your show was on for for
what 3 years three and a half years
three and a half years and it was the
top show everybody is watching it
everybody you're but it wasn't because
of me the whole idea that I just chose a
different direction to make it um funny
but also deep so the people that the the
crazy jokes I wouldn't try that I
wouldn't be writing that crazy jokes
it's about the direction and how to uh
utilize these jokes and utilize the the
direction so a lot of people come to me
like ah jokes ha I said like and I will
tell them these jokes are not taking us
anyway you're just like these are
circular jokes my my my style was how
can we use the jokes in order to um
Advance what we want to say so me I was
kind of like the older guy by then by
that time I was older I was 37 all of
the kids were like 24 so they were all
about like the zingers and the punchline
and it's like yes we going to use that
but in what context so for me it's more
of like I'm the manager I'm telling them
like we need to have the the the the
comedy we need to have because there was
other political satire show but they all
failed because they were all about like
the the cheap laughs the cheap laughs
the quick laugh for me it was sticks
versus storytelling yeah for me it was
like all about like storytelling was
like a beginning and a middle and end of
what that segment what will it be like
what how the people would leave feeling
about that so that was me interesting
but I'm I as a kind of like haha comedy
hilarious I was not the best one when
you were on Pierce did you did you write
did you write what you were going to say
or you just kind of said it you didn't
know what you were going to say no I I'm
a nerd I write everything so when you
went on Pierce you were prepared on what
you were going to tell Pierce got it
okay had a chart yeah he had a chart no
no no the no but the liner I'm not
talking about the chart the whole thing
about the homelander that's what I'm
saying about theistic neopath all of
that was planned all of that was planned
okay now this makes sense so you're a
preparer is what you would say you're an
over preparation type of guy yeah and
the whole thing when I told him like so
what does how does Israel think that
that would go on it's like well in order
to um intimidate the people and they
making some sort well you just compared
Israel to Isis so all all of these traps
I it was it was prepared what year did
you make this transition from the
medical field to Comedy that was 2011 uh
2011 2011 I was uh at that time I was an
attending doctor I uh had my masters I
had my MDS and I I passed my USM exams
and I already applied to um Fellowship
in Cleveland and I was waiting for it
and as I was waiting the Arab Spring
happened so I I made these videos and I
thought like you know maybe I'll put
these videos like online or something
and after one year somebody will
discover me and get me as a writer on a
television show like that so the the in
two weeks it went viral and then by 3
weeks I'm just getting television offers
who called you who called you
first uh everybody uh Al jazer ala
CBC on TV all of these like the local
channels and then some of the Gen the
regional channels start string to all
and then we end up with a smaller
television show they didn't give us the
big amount the biggest amount of money
but they gave us a little bit of freedom
and then after one episode we started to
go do wanted to do with life audience
and uh and I did that because I visited
the John Stewart offices to Shadow his
team and I didn't I wasn't asking for
more just just one selfie with John but
then he came in I like oh I know about
you would you like to come on the show
it's like yes so invited me on the show
and then we made a promise it's like do
you promise me to come to the show if I
made it the life Audience Show he said I
promis the year later he came to my show
that is so cool what year was that that
you went to see John Stewart I went to
see him 2011 and 2012 he came to my show
so 2011 I'm just trying to understand
your background 2012 and then 2013 he
came so 2011 the Arab Springs going on
in you know 2005 2006 it's going on in
Egypt the the the the Arab Spring
started 2011 oh there wasn't okay wasn't
there an earlier okay so back to Egypt
you had uh LC DC uh now you had Mubarak
you had um morsey there all upheavals
going on in your country let me let me
give so before 2011 Mubarak was there
Mubarak was for there for 30 years yeah
and when when I I joke about this like I
was like oh my God you had a present for
30 years and I say in the Middle East
that's a very short the first time first
time and and then uh so Mubarak didn't
survive 2011 mhm he was taken over by
the the Army and then they did elections
Muslim brother who won the election so
now it's like an islamist kind of uh uh
it's it's it's an
islamist authority so uh when they
someone is on Authority you make fun of
them so of course the islamist who used
to like me now said like oh you're doing
this because you you hate Islam you're
an islamophobe we have we have that
things too you guys have islamophobe
yeah if you make this listen words like
islamophobe transphobe racist
anti-semite what ever all of this is
used in order to shut down conversation
so instead of actually trying to have
you like if I say something about Islam
or about Islam political Islam you can
discuss like discuss the thing whatever
is happening with Israel happening or
you can just shut it down oh you're
anti-site Islam and that that is like a
very simplistic and conversation killer
back to what I was asking so you meet
John Stewart you know they say that luck
is when preparation meets opportunity
right like you're starting to be a
medical doctor but obviously you you're
politically Savvy you know what's going
on socioeconomic you understand Islam
you meet this Jewish guy John Stewart
you know we just saw you do the Mark
Twain award where you
sarcastically you know poured love out
to him it was it was a great speech
describe that relationship you know he's
a Jewish guy massive in media in 2011
2012 Obama's president he's still doing
the daily show he retires in 2016 right
before Trump comes in best time for him
to probably be there we all saw what
happened The Daily Show with Trevor Noah
now he's off describe that relationship
what did he do for you what did you try
to mirror with John Stewart The Good the
Bad the Ugly he's Jewish you're Muslim
just give us a little background so I
was watching John Stewart since 2003
2004 we we we at that time we used to
watch it on YouTube and the first time I
saw him I didn't understand what was he
saying so in order to understand I had
to educate myself about Republicans and
about Democrats and
about I because it seems to be very
funny but I didn't understand the
political context so for me John Stewart
became the source of American politics
and I was fascinated how people can make
fun of politics that good so I had this
dream of mine for for eight years that I
would have same a certain show like this
in Egypt so I would even like write uh
certain um like draft
of television shows and make up the but
you know and then but I kind of like
left it like we're living under a
dictatorship there's no way this is
going to happen and then when 2011
happened and the show
exploded
uh the uh the Foreign Press started to
come and see those people in Egypt all
of those people in the political
activist the Revolution and then of
course they came and talked to me and
the first English speak English speaking
publication was The Daily Beast MH and
on that day I decided to plug John
Stewart in every single way possible so
they would say what's your inspiration
John Stewart what do you eat three times
a day John Stewart who do you dream over
John Stewart so so it worked because the
the headline of that article was bassim
Yousef the John Stewart of the N
and since then it caught up so my name
and John Stewart became synonymous
synonymous that's great and that was for
me important so they will know outside
so when by the time that I did I asked
to Shadow his team his team already
knows about me he already knew about me
so when I went in all I wanted to have
like a selfie with him and just Shadow
his team but he said he saw me he's like
hey dude how are you let's go to my
office we sat in his office I thought we
said for 5 days we sat there talking for
an hour and a half B when when so that
relationship's built and you're looking
at it style you're like well I'm going
to do the same model here right but in
America you can get away making fun of
presidents and political powers and all
this stuff and you're the first satire
TV show in the Middle East type of thing
this is not a business model in the
Middle East it's not like hey I'm going
to go be the first this yeah there's a
reason why there's not this in the
Middle East right because they don't
when was it when you pushed the envelope
with a joke or something you you guys
said where you got a knock and you're
like hey man you know all this stuff is
fine but you're kind of like increasing
the temperature and this this joke is
not going to fly here it was with every
single episode every single episod
because um we're trying the there was
political satire in the Arab world
before I did it but it was a kind of a
satire that avoids the
obvious we talk we we don't talk about
the president we talk about the minister
we talk don't talk about the Prime
Minister we talk about like the low life
you know employees here like when the
president went out I would just like
mock him and that was something
unprecedented so when the Muslim
Brotherhood came to a power they were
not very popular by many people they
still have like a huge base so I started
making fun of them and for a lot of
people like yeah like those islamist
yeah they may may had to be make fun but
the islamists were very angry now when
the islamists were removed by the army
that was the the the challenge because
the Army is on touchable the Army is
much more sacred than religion so I
started kind of like trading around it
and that was enough for me to get
canceled once and twice I got
interrogated and arrested under a Muslim
Brotherhood and I got canceled twice and
had my um signal jammed a couple of
times under the Army and uh and I was
going to jail under the Army and then
they last minute I left in November 254
was it did anybody know you were leaving
or no what the people know you were
leaving no they they came up with a
verdict uh Finding Me £150 million which
is about $15 million at the time uh for
um for legal issues with my channels of
course they will choose other kind of
they're not going to say because of
freedom of speech so my lawyer said like
you need to leave of the country right
now so the vertical was at 12:00 noon
4:00 I was I was out out this November
11 2014 yeah and and when you left
you're leaving how are you leaving like
uh underground leaving or you just went
straight to the airport the flight but
they didn't put they they didn't have
time to put my name on wow yeah so so
from that point so right now B like
right now are they like if you went back
would you be flagged would they be like
hey back I I don't think so I have an
American passport now and they're trying
to be nice to me and I don't care good
they uh and they met sent a lot of
people to kind of you know it it's you
don't with with authoritarian regimes
like this you don't know because one day
somebody from them said hey it's your
country you need to come back and the
next day I land in Jordan uh on the way
to Paris and I get detained to be
delivered for the Egyptian and you don't
know who you're talking to you m like
one day they tell you oh you're there's
nothing wrong with bass he can come any
day and the next day they send me
hecklers in my shows in New York to to
spoil my show this is when 2014 2015
2016 how long did that last uh it it did
that like for five times and then when I
and then the New Yorker wrote about that
it's actually you can find it in the New
Yorker called the hackling of the John
Stewart of Egypt uh I actually I'm happy
that they have a cartoon of me on the
New Yorker so it's called the heckling
of the John St of Egypt and the reporter
there attended it and he actually
described how here is yeah how the
people of the pro military people who
were in Washington and New York were
were haggling me and they were shouting
at me and even one of them
went up and sang the Egyptian national
anthem in the middle of my comedy show
so it's it's it's crazy like one day you
ah you're fine he you're our son he's
Egyptian you can come back to your
country and then the next day you do
that wow who wants you to shut up who
wants to keep you silent you know you
see what happens with Salon Rashi
there's a fatwa on him I'm not saying
that's the case here but clearly there's
people that are like shut your mouth who
wants you to keep your silent the most
in any regime in any regime you will
have the doves and the and the Hawks
there's always there's always the people
no every thing is f like no they should
die in every single regime there's
always like that so I don't I think like
the uh the nicer people want me back and
the kind of like the vicious ones wants
me that but the Egyptian regime under
LCC specifically yeah okay but but but
you'll find that in any regime not just
CeCe if it was in Islamic regime you'll
find doves and and vultures seem but um
yeah seems that the the the doves always
try to get me get me back and the
vultures want to but at the end of the
day the the Hawks or the vultures as you
call them they're going to be the
resounding voice in these regimes B so
basam you come here you're in the states
you're doing standup you're doing your
thing are you immediately getting a show
signed working making money and are you
was terrible I came here in a 3 four
years of Darkness yeah that's what I'm
uh I try to do little gigs here and
there and and uh I was not making it it
was terrible and the problem is when
you're trying to do something here you
you already have the massive following
that followed me in the in the Middle
East and then they come and see me doing
little things because I cannot come here
and just like you know Hit the Floor
running and one of it is the did like
some YouTube sketches I did some standup
and I sucked because that I I I needed
to learn something in my second language
and I was not good like anybody who
starting anything knew and I I they
would come to my show and I can see the
disappointment in their eyes and I can
very disappointment and I would like go
go back for very long crying nights
saying I'm done I'm a husband and and it
took me took me some while are you
married at the time like when you came
here married I'm married all through
yeah okay got it and and while you're
going through this uh uh have you made
already Millions on top of millions of
dollars that you've saved so you don't
have to make money ever again like are
cuz you're living in New York it's very
expensive live in New York I live in Los
Angeles okay at the time you didn't come
to New York you went straight to La no I
uh I I went for Dubai for a a few months
stayed with people who helped me and
then I went to uh
Northern San Francisco in Oakland I
stayed with people and then I moved to a
small very small apartment in Los
Angeles and you don't have money at this
time uh I do but it was they were like
dingling they were like because a lot of
stuff that I couldn't get out of Egypt
so uh um so financially I wasn't very
doing very well and and I was just like
doing gigs like speaking universities or
whatever but I said I cannot do go to
university speak to say the same thing
all over and over again so I started to
do my own act so I started doing standup
comedy and the first two years it it was
terrible so the little money I had I
went to hire comedians to so they can
see me perform I didn't hire them to
write me jokes because I I knew what
kind of story I would I would tell but I
want them to kind of punch up my my
style it's not it's not also about the
uh writing mhm it's
about the Cadence and the Rhythm and the
speed and the delivery which is
different from one language to the other
so I had to learn that in a language
that's not mine so you can you can say
it's not like a getting like an Arabic
joke and you translate it into English
so I had to kind of rewire my brain and
it was terrible as I as I said in the
beginning and only two years ago it
became better and my English standup
comedy has actually been touring and
filling like theaters and uh and con
Club so it's been going well and so when
the Pierce Morgan came it seems that it
came in the right time because if the
Pierce Morgan came thing came like two
two years ago I wouldn't been ready
people who come and see they will see
like a bad show but now they come to see
someone oh he's actually like a good
comedian whether in English and in
Arabic so I think it's it the timing was
perfect and there's not there's not that
many people about that can do like both
language standup comedy so you're doing
an hour and hour yeah uh the Arabic show
is a little bit longer an hour and a
half the English show is an hour yeah
and uh we've been doing now very new
experiences so just the Improv in Irvine
I did a whole weekend in Arabic and
that's the first time ever like a a
franchise Comedy Club will actually host
something that's not in English here in
Miami I'm doing two two Arabic and three
English in the same weekend that's
awesome so the the the fact that you
bring in another language to The Comedy
Club not just that you're bringing
another audiences to come see Arabic the
what they love about the the other um
com comedy clubs they say you bring
people that they will never see because
Arabs is not part of their culture to
come and send them comedy show they go
out to eat the movies cemas Ms to come
in and get seated and listen to Comedy
someone speaking to them like that yeah
that's very
and I'm pretty sure cuz we're you know
we're Middle Eastern I can't only
imagine cuz that rarely happens an
Arabic guy coming to do stand up comedy
imagine the audience but imagine the
response of people like hey where are
all these damn brown people coming from
people must be shocked like who the hell
are all these but you know there there's
an element to that that happened in golf
right Tigers started playing golf you
know everybody's like hey you know I'm
interested you know I thought it was
only a white man sport no I want to play
the game and and you bring you know
there's a some of that happens a little
like when I went to Ma show Moss had
bunch of you know Persians you know even
tan tan is an interesting character
right black Persian guy getting up there
and funny as hell you know first time I
saw Terron perform was man probably over
a decade ago and he says let me guess
you look like an Iranian Finance guy
that drives a 750 BMW I'm sitting next
to Jenna I'm like a [__] I came with the
BMW Bingo yeah so you know it's it's
it's a it's it's great to see that it's
great to see what's happening now the
fact that the timing of it of when it
took off where you're actually are able
to also deliver on the performance side
let's talk about uh actually me me and
me and tahran are going to together to
Dubai May 24th oh fantastic big double
Bill fantastic Dubai is the the one of
the few countries in the Middle East
where you can just say what you want to
say without the fear of getting your
head chopped off no you can you know you
have Dubai you have Bahrain you have
Kuwait you have uh the Gulf States
Lebanon you have Lebanon too Lebanon
I I I played on all of these but not
Egypt uh not
me it's actually like russle Peters was
just in in Egypt so was it are there any
Middle Eastern countries you just would
not feel safe going or just complet
completely uncomfortable go on there
telling jokes what what countries for
now for me Egypt straight up like would
you go to Afghanistan would you go to
Iraq would you go to Syria Afghanistan
no Syria no IRA
no would you ever perform in Israel no
you would not no why they would accept
you I don't accept them you don't accept
Israel the state of Israel no I don't
accept them taking care of me getting in
that's the problem problem is when you
go in in Israel it's not about going in
Israel or not it's that the fact that
they really show you a terrible time you
go in in the security they treat you
like [__] really yeah I mean I've been
invited by Palestinians all lowed to go
to there and so like I would go to you
but like I don't want to deal with the
border control of Israel it's just they
because they humilate you they and
that's because you're Arab or that's
because because but they have 20% of
their population is Arab they're not
leaving yeah but they're teaching them
like shits not not according to them
I've seen them I've met them I met them
too I mean they they don't have um they
like you talk about the 20% of
Palestinians I'm talking about the 20%
of of Israelis are Muslims are Arabs if
given a choice to move to any other
Middle Eastern
country given the state of circumstances
in the Middle East they would choose a
100 times out of 100 to stay in the
Democracy of Israel why don't they leave
have you have you talked to them about
their health care and their schools
because they're they're they about like
25 uh Arab cities that they don't have
hospitals or schools they have to take
in Gaza in the West Bank no I'm talking
about inside Israel I'm talking about
Arabs with Israeli passports fully
fledged Israeli citizens they don't have
a single Cinema they don't have a single
hospital they don't have a single School
in their cities and they have to go to
the Jewish States in order to go there
there are many many many many daily
microaggressions against the Arabs who
live in Israel having the Israeli
passport even within the Israeli pass
Israeli Community you have
slurs
like which actually that the n word
M they're I mean I can go on and on and
on about slurs are going to be
everywhere in America where we're all
equal there's slurs every day I get
called a dirty Jew you think I'm crying
no but like every day here if you find
someone's like [__] [__] [__]
[__] you that will be yeah basically
200 years of America exactly but like
when you have like one part of them was
much more stronger and control the other
one and all they do is like slurs
because the Arabs canot do Slayers
against the Jewish so why don't they
leave well some of them actually they
because it is basically it is between a
like a rock and a hard place mhm yeah
they the whole idea about like Arabs
living a Wonderful Life they're living
good life compared to other Arabic
countries which is a really low bar and
the fact that like can use like a low
bar to sell like at least they're happy
nose like I'm living here because I
don't know where else to go I appreciate
you saying that because the bar in many
many Middle Eastern countries is very
low I'm not coming here to defend any
countries in I know you're not I'm
asking
I'm just saying that the security and
the um in equality that Israel wants you
to think that they have it between all
of their Arabs it is not true they have
something called zoning uh committees
where you as an Arab coming in as to get
an auction to get a house in a in a
Jewish town you will not be allowed to
take it and it happened more and more
and more before it happened in Nazarite
it happened in many cities that I
actually talked about the uh there was
like an auction where they found that
the most of the people who are getting
the the houses were Arabs and the city
canceled the auctions and they canceled
the auctions saying that we want to
preserve the city of
Tara as uh a Jewish Zionist secular
country so I don't know how zist Zionist
and and secular and and would and
Zionist come in the same city so MH
it's interesting to what what question
you're asking right because like I'll
sit there and and if you want to read
this real quick I'll sit there and I'll
talk to my friends in California and
I'll say Hey you know California this I
hate California I hate this I hate that
I hate this and he y why don't you leave
I can't leave California why can't you
leave California well because my
family's here my you's here my kids are
here my uncle my aunt my grandma da d d
okay got it but I hated here I wish I
was living in Texas or I was living in
Florida whatever okay some people here I
can't believe you know okay why don't
you leave why I can't you know this this
that we lived in Iran we left lived in
Teran for 10 years and I mean I went to
school there till fifth grade I read
right farsy everything till I left and I
went to Germany right I lived in Germany
for year and a half and then we finally
get here like holy [__] we make it to
America right it's like a dream but the
the the people that the it's not the
people that can't
leave that give the argument of why
don't they leave it's the people that
can leave that choose to stay why do you
choose to stay like I'd love to have a
room full of 50 people who are Arabs who
can choose to leave Israel why are you
not leaving make sense just to kind of
get an idea what would you say why are
you not leaving right if you have the
ability to leave you can go to a
different place why don't you why why do
2 million people in Gaza being bmed
every single day for 100 days why don't
they leave because that's their land
right that so you can be living in a
very shitty situation but you will not
leave because you know that you're not
going to get back again there's those
people living as a 2.2 million people
they're living under subhuman conditions
they could leave as a matter of fact
everybody pushing them to leave through
S whatever and say no we will not leave
because this is our land sometimes you
get connected to the land and it doesn't
matter how bad so to answer your
question why don't you leave because
that's your land yeah I'm talking about
the Arabs in Israel but yeah the because
they considered that still their land
yeah but the there's so many different
ways we can have this conversation but
everything for me comes down to
socioeconomics okay to me I'm always
wondering why is the Gaza the
Palestinian plight at the Forefront of
the news all right now we're starting to
see Yemen in the news people don't
realize for 10 years there have been a
civil civil war with the houti rebels
Saudis sunnis Shiites Iranian back
militants killing each other never in
the news Syria tens and tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people murdered we know what's going on
in Iraq what's going on in Afghanistan
this is not an anomaly in the Middle
East but in my opinion humbly with all
due respect what's going on in Gaza is
the equivalent of BLM in the states what
do I mean
so black-on-black crime every single
weekend in Baltimore in DC in Chicago
you name the city there's black-on-black
crime Let One Cop kill a black guy
George Floyd National international news
in the Middle East Yemen Syria Lebanon
you name it Iraq every day Muslims are
killing other Muslims a lot of it is
islamists fundamentalists there's no
there's no marches there's no protests
but Israel defends itself after October
7th and I've seen you condemn Hamas for
October 7th but you've also sympathize
with Palestinians as you should but all
of a sudden that's the biggest story in
the news why the distinguishment why
can't Muslims say differ between
comparing conflicts Civil War and then
allowing another country to bomb you
from the sky every single day for 100
days you cannot compare the both and
actually your tone of voice when you say
oh there is like black and black Arabs
killing each other in your undertone is
saying yeah they don't deserve to live
so let's Israel this is
exactly that's not what I no no this is
what saying I asked a question you're
reading you you have absolutely no
sympathy for the Palestinian killing
because not your don't put words my wife
no no no seriously I 100% have sympathy
your your your entrance into this
conversation is extremely racist because
you say well Arabs have been killing
each other first of all the Arabs have
been killing each other these are called
either proxy wars or Civil Wars but you
this is different because a the America
is not standing but behind Saudi Arabia
voting every single uh UN resolution
like like Israel Israel is killing
Palestinians and nobody can do anything
for them in the UN or the security
Council right you can talk about how
Saudis are killing the houis or the
amage or how Iran but when they go to
the security Council America doesn't use
the vote The veto you know how many
vetos did America use since the
Inception of the security Council how
many tell me
88 how many of those were they used in
in order to protect Israel from a
veto 56
oh the superpower of the world over 50
years used more than 65% of its veto
power to protect one one country you
cannot compare both so why do you think
that is why is Israel so aligned with
Israel I'm sorry why is us so aligned
with Israel Over Gaza I don't know I
mean there's like a mil there's a mil
there's a why why I to know you tell me
because they're white like them are they
allowed to who well I mean a lot of
Americans consider Israel is the white
but you know for for a fact most
Israelis are saric and they are brown
it's the perception bull the perception
it's a perception you know so this is
this is how Israel like promotes itself
we are a secular we are democratic
country I have never seen a secular or
Democratic country that would actually
give contraception shots to its own
citizens to their Ethiopian Jews and
make them them not to reproduce and
until 2013 they have confessed doing
that they have been doing this for 10
years that is not a democratic country I
have never he heard a secular country a
democratic country that would kidnap
little kids from Yen Jews in 1950 and
then take them away and then tell their
parents that they die and they did that
in order to instill um uh citic uh DNA
in their population that's why DNA that
that's why DNA testing is not allowed in
Israel so are you uh Pro Islam are you
anti-israel or both I'm not pro anything
or I'm I'm Pro Humanity man it it
doesn't matter my religion is I don't
care actually and I can give you a 100
things I can tell you about Islamic
countries that they do wrong but what
happens what happens is right now is
that the people who are bombing people
only every single day they are not
yemenis they're not huis they're not
Saudis they're Israelis for 100 days
they have brought they have dropped
almost three nuclear weapons on an open
air PR prison and all because of Hamas
dude if Isis was already there you have
no excuse to kill 30,000 people you
can't say words like nuclear weapons
when it's not true bosam and you know
that equivalent the equivalent the
equivalent of three no I can't I can't I
can't so now they're dropping nuclear
weapons that's what trying to me on this
I said like they're dropping the
equivalent of three nuclear weapon so
how many people have died in Gaza 30,000
people okay according to um Hamas
obviously un gets their number from
Hamas but over the last do you have a
number that you trust no I don't have
any number that I trust but I'll take
your word for it I don't think that
sounds so how many so how many how many
hundreds of thousands of Muslims have
died how many people in Israel died in
October 7th according to the numbers
1200 but according to who but the
numbers are still being counted
according to whom according to the IDF
oh but I don't trust the
IDF whether you do or you don't those
are the numbers that we're working with
well I'm giving you 50,000 people Di
and you said you don't trust them so do
we trust that's not what I said I said
according to Hamas yeah whether I
believe when you say according to Hamas
it's like it's the under that you don't
believe the numbers with with with all
due respect you're missing my point
30,000 other than the Hamas Fighters CU
I will I will stand to kill these people
I I hope zero civilians die but we know
what happens but they die of course
every day but but but let's go back to
my initial question me let me ask this
question and then you can s how do you
think how many what about zero stop zero
but they're killing it okay but that's
not my point B my point is this 30 many
can I ask can I ask the question and
then you can have the full fill response
why is this issue at the Forefront of
the news when hundreds of thousands
since 911 5 million plus people in the
Middle East have died 5 million 5
million versus
30,000 where the where the marches where
the where the protest you haven't been
our you just haven't been around no but
I also read the newspapers I see what's
going on because there has been there
has been marches against against what
happened in Yemen there have been
massive Maring against what happened in
Iraq if you ask the average person they
couldn't tell you that there's a war in
Yemen difference but if you ask the
average American they know what is
exactly going on in Israel here's the
thing here's the thing these uh mental
gymnastics where you want to divert
people to other conflicts these
conflicts are proxy wars these conflicts
are civil war terrible horrible Civil
War there's been Civil War happening in
all kind of Asian and African country
the only difference is that that is a
foreign country invading another country
like exactly Russia invaded Ukraine and
then everybody is sitting there all they
ask is ceasefire because one of the
people in that conflict is a country
that has been uh financed given money by
the US it is considered as part of the
free war because they are secular
because they are democratic and they are
committing war crimes every single day
under the eyes of the United States of
the UN in the security Council and that
is why it is different fair enough so
Civil Wars are totally okay if it's a
civil war don't look it those are people
just doing their I ever say that Civil
War but you basically equivalized let's
of a Civil War 5 million people die
across the Middle East yeah it is ter
because usually the Civil War is really
supported by like two proxy people and
they are like killing each other and
it's terrible and they're trying to do
it and in the same time those people are
not just like killing them they're
killing them wanted to push them out
openly saying that we are going to push
Palestinians into the Sinai basically
that is my country all right you have
the only people shouting for The River
To The Sea are the gazin well Palestine
will be free so what does a free
Palestine you you know what's the
difference between regular people in the
street shouting from the river and the
Sea these are regular people that are
carrying Flags in the street you know
what's happened on the other side you
have government official like B like the
the uh Minister of Finance you have
benir who is the Minister of National
Security both of them by the way were
uh arrested many times for acts of
terrorism against their own country
these are Israeli Prime Ministers they
these the minister not the prime
ministers Ministers of certain so do you
mean to tell me that Yaya Sinar who's
the head of Hamas or uh mmud Abbas who's
the head of the pillo they're not
politically saying from The River To The
Sea so if we're going to use that
equivalence you you didn't even finish
making go ahead so first of all you are
comparing a militant group a terrorist
group with a secular Democratic country
this secular democratic country that I'm
telling you about they have ministers
coming up with the map of Greater Israel
behind of them and they openly talk
about them which is by the way if you
don't know the greater Israel map is
from the river to the euphrate including
part of Saudi Arabia Jordan Lebanon and
Syria and of course Palestine so that is
the official Talk of the official
ministers so you want to you know kind
of ignore this and you go after random
people in the streets with flags saying
from The River To The Sea don't you see
the comparison is a little bit well it's
not just random people it is Hamas who
is the governor body of Gaza ham but the
point of a democracy what do you mean
ham at the end of the day they are a
militant group they are a militant group
they are Isis you don't take them
seriously militant group don't take them
seriously they're the leaders of Gaza B
they were elected in 2006 and as your
joke said a 30 year uh 2006 when when
nobody actually was alive by then like
now like people there how many people
who were alive % of Gaza was not alive
in if you did an election right now
they're not going to be the ruler of
Gaza yeah but you didn't do an election
that's the point why is
that why is that because basically they
kicked out F on the PLO and they're
running the West Bank and and and Israel
didn't put them under blade and K the
there there is an argument to be made
there you think that I'm saying that
Israel is completely innocent do you
think I would say that the US is
completely Inn we had a debacle in Iraq
we had debacle in Afghanistan there's no
perfect country there's no there's no
innocent country listen this is this is
what you do and when I say what you do
is what America and Israel and all of
this like Pro let's kill them
all you've already put words in my mouth
you've called me racist you're saying
that I want to kill everybody I've said
none of those words you kill people and
then you ask questions later you kill
people you ask question like isn't that
what Hamas does America did Hamas is a
terrorist group you are comparing Hamas
you every time you compare Hamas I'm
bringing you Israel and is and America
which are supposedly Democratic
countries Hamas and Isis and whatever
these people are not like an ex good
examples right I agree good example so
when he tell all right fine ham horrible
people let's talk about the leaders of
the of the Free World America they
killed first they ask question later and
the result Afghanistan and Iraq is
disasters I'm not going to argue with on
that one dis Israel killed later and
then the result what's happening in Gaza
and what's been happening to Gaza is
there's no justification for Israel to
to kill 30,000 people right now and all
the thing about October 7th many of them
where can you tell me where are the
decapitated babies what are their names
can you get me the names you want me to
you want me to go over every dead
decapitated Israeli baby's name I think
that story was the refuto wasn't it ited
many times it was the biggest story
what's your point that Hamas didn't kill
babies they didn't kill women there's
hundreds of people kidnapped by Hamas
what's your point no no no they're
kidnapped yes if you're saying a
terrorist group would decapitate people
if terrorist group would burn people you
know what terrorist groups does they
terrorize they will show them off like
Isis they were burning people in cages
all right we will not find about the
atrocities of rape or about decapitating
from other sources because the terrorist
group by Design terrorizes they would go
in with their GoPro they will show you
the babies that they decapitated they
will not going to high it's like oh my
we didn't do it because terrorist groups
does that right this remember Isis when
they were burning people in cages they
like to promote their Terror because
terorist group want to ter to terrorize
the public we have not seen anything of
that that's one of the most naive
comments I've ever heard we've seen
videos countless videos of them gang
raping women and then blowing their head
off while they chop off one of their
breasts we've seen these
videos are you [__] crazy of course
we've seen this video we've seen we've
seen dead bodies litter all over K say
you read about it I go watch the videos
you're choosing this is selective
ignorance this is selective ignorance
that's like me saying if that's like me
saying of course Israel is not bombing
indiscriminately no they have and I'm at
least willing to own that and I'm not
Israeli I'm American by the way I'm not
defending H they equalent but what I'm
saying what I'm saying what I'm saying
is all of these like decapitating babies
that is wrong that never happened okay
it was only a few a few how many I dude
I'm not there on the ground so what's
your argument have pictures let be clear
here what's your argum that they didn't
decapitate one baby's head no no I so
what are you saying I said that what
hamz did was terrible but it was
inflated by things to make it emotional
to think that it's okay to kill all of
those people it was inflated so it
wasn't 1,200 well how much was it I
don't know okay so so so is so Israel's
numbers are inflated 1200 but the 30,000
from Hamas is not infl you're talking
out of both sides of your as a matter of
fact according to Israel Israeli
survivors they said that many of these
casualties happened because Israeli um
um troops came in and indiscriminately
killed everybody including the hostages
that's the first time I've heard that
story I've been first time because you
were not covering because you have not
listening to the survivors from the
Israelis on every morning I read
credible sources Wall Street Journal Fox
News Fox News Bloomberg okay so who what
are you reading Hamas decom like where
are you getting your sources hars okay
hars yeah the the Israeli newspaper
Israel yes of course I read those too
they have actually I've never heard them
say one time that 120000 people were not
murdered not in one paper no no no I
didn't say that I said many of those
numbers that were killed they were
killed because of the indiscriminating
interference by the Israeli troops and
many of them died because of four people
were killed that way when they tried to
to rescue the hostages the fact that
you're trying to equivocate 1200 people
late theame you're late in the game
there was a woman that was named Zia she
came out on the an Israeli podcast and
he said that everybody in the kaputs
were died and then we went out and we
said that Israeli tank the one that
fired on the whole kaput this is
[__] stories you think the IDF is
just coming in and just spraying down
kutes that's like saying American troops
are just coming into a conflict here and
just spraying down fellow Americans
calledit it's called the hanimal
protocol look it up yeah we'll look it
up but I think that's [__] B I want
to ask you a question so going going to
that day uh all the stuff that we found
out since that day um what we found out
Rob that uh they knew apparently they
had information intelligence for a year
that it was going to happen the day that
it happened apparently all the defenses
were down Hamas got to run rampant for 6
hours uh Mayhem they asked John Kirby
went up and one of the reporters from
Fox asked how did you guys not see this
with all the intelligence and he said
and I quote now is not the time since
October it's not what three months
October November December we're in
January right now they still don't know
um we saw this thing called the Jericho
wall where Israel a leaked document
where Israel already had a plan of what
to do with all these all the displaced
people they want to send them all uh to
Egypt and all the countries and and the
United States uh BB Netanyahu was on a
video saying how he could do whatever he
wants in Gaza because Americans are
gullible and he could do whatever on on
the home video B what what do you do you
have an opinion on the knowledge the
pre-knowledge of this was going to
happen and the fact that they got to
wait they got to do whatever they want
for 6 hours with one of the sickest
military sickest intelligence you you
think like they knew they let it happen
what what's the how do you feel about I
I not I'm no military expert at all but
like watching this the fact that they've
been doing this for 6 hours and this is
the most guarded border ever MH I mean
you can't even you can't even have a dog
passed by by without being shot and this
these walls has been tried and and and
tested and the fact that they get in and
they continue like the the the wall by
itself is 7 m up 7 m down the ground
it's one of the most fortified borders
ever and then you go in the Apaches
didn't even appear until after 6 hours
that's that doesn't make sense and you
understand like how Israel and Gaza and
all of these these are like very small
these are like very small this is like a
plane can be there in 2 minutes so I
don't know I mean these are the
questions that I I don't want to go into
conspiracy theories but these are the
questions that the Israeli Community has
been asking this kind of f
failure a lot of people inside again
conspiracy theories I don't know I don't
want to adopt any of them it's like it's
because of BB was having a lot of
pressure from his Supreme Court so he
wanted something to kind of like divert
it and you know when people want to
divert something like they make a
conflict MH but it kind of like it it it
got out of hand and the fact you can go
in Lily willly with very
primitive uh weapons and go in inside of
Israel and come up I mean just a year
ago there were 50 Palestinians that they
killed by snipers just because they came
in closer to the road and they were like
holding Flags M so the fact that they go
in and you see like all of these
military uh bases empty for the taking
and coming back with with cars and with
people and with
hostages I mean if I'm an Israeli
citizen I would be pissed of course I
want to ask I I would I would I would
like to have some answers so I I don't
know but B let's go to the last thing
because for me I'm curious with
Solutions right some say well this is
going to keep happening it's never going
to stop it's been going on for hundreds
of years couple thousand years it's
going to be ongoing for another couple
thousand years perfect okay fine so
that's one argument now for the people
that maybe are solution oriented and
they want to figure out a way to you
know improve things you said' 06 Hamas
gets elected because you know what it
was but today it wouldn't happen today
if they do have an election who controls
the election because you you were
you were a little bit uh not elusive you
were not clear about why they're not
having Fair elections today who controls
the election I wish Hamas is not in
charge of I wish the whole thing about
the islamization Judaism of this
conflict is not there because that is
making everything worse the whole idea
about like putting so much religion on
the Israeli side and on the Muslim side
it has actually actually it is the
reason why this conflict is getting
worse and worse and worse it's because
now people are like kind of like rooting
for the Divine and whenever you put
religion in any conflict this is going
to get worse and worse so I thing is
there is a problem a fundamental problem
between for the rights of the
Palestinians in the land of of Palestine
now whether you create
a a Palestinian Nation on the 222% after
with using uh like Jimmy Carter once
said it is it have to have like a two TW
State solution using Gaza using the
borders of 1967 with modification and
land swap that is like and that is what
the Palestinian Authority are actually
accepting Hamas does not accept that and
there's other people who does not accept
that and in the same time people on the
Israeli side does not accept that you
have people radical people on both sides
who want all or none and and kind of
Fairly moderate people who want to stay
in the middle and say all right let's
have a little bit of a swap but what is
happening right now is a one state and
the two- State solution is being shot
and dead a long time ago because even
when he came out and he bragged about
how he have spoiled the oso Accord and
how Americans don't care and we have
manipulated them and 80% of America are
with us so we can do whatever the want
the hell we want Even if we can kill as
many Palestinians as possible and he was
there on camera when he does that and
there's no
repercussions I don't think it's going
to get any better and and I think it's
going to be a matter of time until those
Palestinians will be it's not if not
today it's not this year it's the year
after all of this Gaza will be cleared
out and the Palestinians will be pushed
into into Sinai and Israel will take it
over and it will not stop like that
because if you put two 2.2 million
people put them in in Sinai that will be
a security threat because those people
will have an open access to the Sea and
they will have weapons and then they
will want to avenge what happened to
them and they will go in and attack
Israel and now is going to have a dual
problem between a group of people
between Israel and Egypt and that will
not get any better so I'm I'm I'm I'm
just like telling you I'm not very
optimistic about what will happen
because if you don't have Justice and
you don't have people what they want
they just like people going to get
Justice in themselves and then they
would be called militant terrorists
Freedom Fighters no matter how you call
them but it's not going going well so
regarding Gaza and I'm trying to come
from a solution based approach here to
be
honest at the end of the day everything
comes down to money or security you need
that everything comes down to to money
or
security so you just got to pull your
shirt up oh hold on oh what's going on
heater pad put on he's got a bad back
let's let's get his back right before I
ask this
question look up the shirt that's how we
played massages we got a m we got a mass
coming in the house well thank you guys
because I'm really in a in a in in pain
I can't even you've been traveling for
for how many days I we have what is
called unreasonable Hospitality yeah P
doesn't play while we're having a
friendly debate we're going to make sure
that your back's okay go ahead solution
for Gaza for Israel wants security and
Gaza many countries of Middle East need
and want Prosperity okay Israel's whole
thing their whole contention is listen
we just can't have another October 7th
period and we're going to do everything
to protect our citizens the people in
Gaza they're no different than other
people in the Middle East they want
Prosperity the problem in the Middle
East in my opinion my humble opinion
it's not just an Islamic issue certainly
not just an Israeli issue because is the
by the way it is an Iranian issue that's
the tip of the spe when it comes to the
uh Mafia like regime that's running Iran
over there but it's socioeconomic
there's people need economic
improvements people need political uh
certainty and when you combine that with
Islamic fundamentalism you sprinkle in a
little Jihad throwing a little anti-
zionis Zionism and rhetoric you'll get
what's going on in Gaza but look at the
countries that are thriving in the
Middle East and look at the countries
that are basically the gazes of the
Middle East unemployment rates people
need jobs okay if kids don't have jobs
if you're if youth unemployment is is
skyrocketing what are these young people
supposed to do the highest unemployment
rate in the Middle East Jordan
23% Palestinians right next to them also
at 23% then you have Sudan Libya Tunisia
Lebanon Iraq Yemen Afghanistan Iran
Morocco Syria turkey Egypt All Above 10%
unemployment with the exception of your
country of Egypt 7% every single one of
those countries political uphe
especially what's going on in Iraq
Afghanistan Palestine but did you notice
that all the good countries high
unemployment rate low unemployment rates
Qatar 3% one of the richest countries on
Earth they just had the World Cup there
richest country in the Middle East byin
1.9% Israel 3.3% uuaa 3.4% by the way
the UK's unemployment rate is three 3
and a half% so UAE is better than the UK
KU 3.7% same as the US when people don't
have jobs and they don't have purpose
and they don't have meaning and they
can't work and they can't basically have
political uh econ economic sustenance
for their family they're going to resort
to violence that's why every single one
of those countries that is 10%
unemployment those countries are As
Trump says [__] hole countries but all
the nice countries Qatar UAE they're all
thriving so it's not an Islamic problem
it's an economic problem now if you want
to talk GDP just for my last point the
countries with the lowest GDP per
persons those countries are disasters
Afghanistan you know what the average
person in Afghanistan makes a year
$350 a a year Afghanistan Syria 420
Yemen 650 Sudan 1100 bucks Morocco 3,400
Palestinians above any of those guys
3,700 bucks a year Lebanon 4,000 Egypt
4200 conversely every single rich
country has zero problems Qatar GDP
$887,000 better than the United States
better than United States Israel 55,000
UAE 54,000 Kuwait 40,000 I can go on and
on and on here the bottom line is this
what I've seen in the Middle East it
comes down to socioeconomics then you
sprinkle in a little islamis is islamism
in there why is every rich country in
the Middle East have no problems but all
the poor countries are suicide bombings
terrorists Gaza had the opportunity to
invest billions of dollars into
infrastructure into infrastructure but
they built tunnels and bombs but my
question is B here's my you're wrong
you're wrong Gaza has not built tunnels
and bombs you're wrong you're wrong you
said like as if you the if there was
like some sort of a a prosperous source
of economy and all of as said took that
and put it on in tunnels what you're
missing here is Gaza since 2006 is under
blockade and even the medicine even the
water even the electricity is controlled
by Israel they don't have I'm not asking
you about Gaza I'm asking you about the
Middle East be clear no you want to
focus on Gaza and then you want to turn
it back on Israel I'm asking you
specifically let's not talk about Israel
if that would make you a little bit
nervous talk about Israel for the next
countries in in the Arab world so we can
prove that Arabs could be bombed at any
time because we [__] poor no that's
not what I'm saying do that's exactly
what you're saying they're just like
poor people killing each other and we
just like there watching them I'm I'm
sorry that dude I like you but seriously
you're under tone is [__] racist from
the beginning until the end you are
looking at those people are lesser
people who have made bad choices and
because they are poor they are okay to
be [__] bomed by Israel okay this is
the third time you've used the racist
word I've never said that once about you
your undertone is very very very
offensive for so when I read stats yeah
yeah you don't like my tone when I read
stats you you read the stats basically
telling people like you see because
they're rich they got this to themselves
the the rich people are better the poor
people are okay so we can't have to kill
them every that's not what I said and
you're putting words in my mouth and
it's actually super disrespectful I'm
reading stats to you I'm saying how can
we uplift the poor countries in the
Middle East how can we the blade that's
number one no no no no I said the Middle
East funny remove the BL I said the
Middle East you're talking about Gaza
I'm naming all these countries that are
thriving Qatar bin UAE Israel Silicon
Valley of the Middle East what can be
done with the countries that are quote
unquote [__] holes okay give me a
country like a [__] hole give me an
example I'm looking at the unemployment
rates in all these countries give me one
country Afghanistan Syria Afghanistan
lean why Afghanistan got became a [__]
whole country because they endorsed the
Taliban they did they did isn't that a
little bit of a reductive way to tell
history because at the beginning there
was no Taliban and then the Soviet Union
came in and then America came in
supported the Taliban made them bigger
than they were and then at the end of
the day they support if you remember
Rambo 3 Rambo 3 was supporting the
Taliban so Taliban was really cool and
even they were they were even hailed by
right-wing Christians as Freedom
Fighters anti-communist and then what
happened America some people like the
Richard Wilson wall wanted him to come
in to put some schools that no no no we
spend we spend all of this money of
tanks on on weapons we don't need to put
them schools what happened Taliban
flourished all because of America
interfered made it Shy left everything
Taliban froed it and then America went
in again spent $2 billion makeing it
even two Terran laws made it even worse
so when you tell me like a country is
not surviving it's not because oh
because there are bad people they no you
have to come into the root cause every
single country that you said I can bring
you the root coast of how America and
the West has [__] this country to
become go to Syria go to Lebanon go to
there Bashar Al Assad killing his own
people gassing his own people tell me
that's americ who who's he supported who
was he supported by that's the whole
problem in the Middle East you have
Sunni you have Shi you've got houti
Rebels you got you got um every single
country in quack Aid and then surrounded
by Islamic terrorists every single midle
figure it out Bashar husin is not is not
you cannot really put Bashar husin as a
Islamic car thing you know because no CU
he's fighting Isis which we're funding
Isis to fight against B who fing
you tell me Qatar wasun funded by the
United States all right so yeah you
don't understand you see this is how
complicated because I do understand how
complicated it is people in the Middle
East are either supported by Russia or
supported by America and they're
fighting each other so at the end of the
day you have people who have come to
power because they have been supporting
by one of the superpower and they're
fighting is against each other you know
you have you you have the hamti and you
have the the Army in Sudan each one of
them is supported by external Powers so
so it's not about like the islamization
of them it's not about the economy is
bad because at the end of the day these
are Warlords who are fighting against
each other but to reduce that in order
why don't can just like make some money
while you while you completely ignore
the power of the international powers
that are involved into that like for
example the country like Mali Mali is
like very very restless and the reason
Mali is restless that sparis is there
and it's putting up like some sort of a
puppet president so so Paris can
continue taking its share of gold and
putting into into its coffers so there
is it's much more complicated than just
selling islamization or n islamization
all of these power of play you just gave
me a Taliban and I give you the reason
why America did that Saddam Hussein
Saddam Hussein right s Hussein he was
the baby of the of the United States
Administration and then he went in and
he invaded KU who gave him the money who
gave him that kind of power all right it
has been going on forever the superpower
are using this the the the smaller
country
and they are controlling their own
leaders in order to go fight each other
because at the end of the day it works
for them no there's no you're I'm in
full agreement with you that it's a
mystery wrapped in a riddle wrapped in a
quagmire what's going on in the Middle
East and I'm in full agreement with you
that there are proxy wars all over the
Middle East no doubt but the tip of the
spear that's funding all the chaos Pat
has said that this is the year of chaos
the tip of the spear with the chaos is
Iran and there's no I mean who's funding
Iran China China Russia they have a
relationship AER they have some sort of
relationship how do you deal with Iran
because Iran's greatest export let's
Bomb It Well we haven't done it yet no
no let's bomb it I I I don't think we
should bomb I think we should no let's
bomb it then let's let's elect you for a
government official and you're no better
than what's going on you're no better
than the Min so you're the Nikki Camp go
for it that's the answer bomb
Afghanistan bomb Iraq bomb Palestine
bomb Iran and let's see what happens I
speak
better than the next guy I trust you I
know you're being but what do you do
about Aime that is funding H Hamas
Hezbollah they are the ones who are
sewing Discord what do you do about Iran
I I remember like colen Powell in the
security Council let's bomb Iraq and
then they bombed Iraq how is bombing
Iraq had done to this country it was a
[__] disaster oh yeah really but it
will not be a [__] disaster to bomb
Iran right I'm agreeing with you I know
that you're speaking SAR so people
watching you say like oh it's all about
Iran it's all it starts like this of
course it is all about who's funding the
H who's funding Hezbollah who's funding
Hamas billions of dollars they're giving
to terrorist organizations years ago and
you just want IGN that 10 20 years ago
it was Iraq and 20 years ago it was
Afghanistan and they bond them I got a
question for both of you I got a
question for both of you I'm I'm
actually really curious and uh uh uh
listen to both of you guys this is my
question okay the part that both of you
guys agree that we had a guy on couple
only guy you know one of the guys I've
had on a couple times his name is John
Perkins he wrote a book called the
economic Hitman I don't know if you've
read the book you know who he is okay
and one of the things he talked about
the model on what it was they go to
president and he that's what he did by
the way this was his job okay he goes to
a country that has a natural resource or
location oil it's close to something
that they can have some kind of control
and they go to them and they say here's
what we're going to be doing we're going
to come here
and we're going to bring billions of
dollars of infrastructure to your
country however here's what you're going
to give us okay and and the president
who said no he says couple of them they
killed oh [__] that was his job okay and
in he doesn't say he killed them but he
says if you said no when I went back and
had to report back to the people that I
work for that you're say no to guess
what bad things are going to happen to
you and your family wow and it happened
then the next model was we come we bring
infrastructure then we make the country
go bankrupt then you give us everything
then we control you are we naive enough
to believe that's what China is doing
now exactly but but but pre- China we
did that America did that and others
have done that and Russia's done that
other people and UK is UK tried to do
that to Iran and then later on
eventually UK US you know Germany France
these guys got rid of the Sha because
you know you know coup and all the
people have involved with economic
Hitman for a long time here's a question
for you bam here's a question for you
Adam okay so we both agree that that's
going on okay we both agree that that's
been going on for many decades no one
can even dispute it nowadays but now
we're in this [__] hole and what I mean
by [__] [__] show is insanity everywhere
bosam what do you do now is it more from
the standpoint where a part of you was
almost not optimistic you're like Pat I
don't even I I think this thing's going
to go and nothing's going to happen it's
going to continue all this other stuff
right what do we do now we were told uh
uh during uh uh 2015 2016 when it was a
debate between what Hillary Clinton and
Trump yeah and what were we told if
Trump becomes a president he war is
going to happen this is what's going to
happen so everybody we're all like oh
[__] it's going to be pretty bad this
guy's going to have a do you really want
this guy to have the finger on the butt
okay he goes in Isis disappears there's
no war it's quiet lowkey everything's
good boom boom boom and then no and then
boom Biden gets elected he's going to be
peace he's going to bring everybody
together he's going to bring this he's
going to then he comes in and you know
Afghanistan happens within months $83
billion equipment being left and he got
Ukraine Russia then he got this and then
there's a bunch of guys economists that
are talking about you know this is
China's year to try to invade Taiwan
because taiwan's got an election coming
up it's a [__] show basically is what
you're saying but the but the point is
like there's so many contradictions and
politics as well at a point like this
bosam where you know mainstream media is
not going to tell us the real story
because they're maybe not even getting
the real story themselves on what's
Happening behind closed doors what do
you do today there is one of the most
advanced military armies in the region
in the world supported by the West
supported by America have vote open
voting like they diverting their vote
all over and they're killing people for
all that time and nobody is doing
anything for who are you talking about
I'm talking about Israel okay all right
so the killing has to stop and I'm not
talking about Gaza I'm talking about
what they doing in the West Bank every
single day in the West Bank that all of
these people are being killed in the
West Bank and there's no Hamas came out
from West Bank to do the the the 7th of
October all right just a couple of days
ago like a woman was walking with her
children St up snap walking the street
that is the regular days of people in
the West Bank do you think the problem
is Gaza what you see in Gaza is an
accelerated exaggerated form of what's
Happening in the West Bank too so you
have a country that has occupied the
land and they are like G making people
living like animals and if you deal
people with like animals they will come
up as animals right that is the Crux of
all we can talk about politics and about
economy it's here till kingdom comes
what is happening is there is in is
horrible Injustice happening every
single day they're taking people strip
them up saying them that're Hamas they
they are like you have like you have
like an 11 person being killed every
hour
you have
247 person being killed every day that
is in 5 days that is the, 1400 people
that were killed in this October 7th you
have 30,000 people and I think is when
you say 20,000 30 numbers don't care
don't mean anything anymore if I told
you a million people died in gam you
will not flinch because their numbers
have became so it's true see it's no
nobody I don't I don't disagree so we go
into these circular motions how can we
stop that again how no there is killing
happening every day my wife's family
have actually Che cheated death so far
for 100 days because they've been
running from kanun to ra back to yunus
and they were told in the beginning that
kanun and RAF are the safe place because
it's in the house and then they were
telling them these are the safe path
take this safe path these are the buses
they run into the buses and Israel will
bomb the buses after being guaranteed
that this is the safe path this is
murder every day so I don't know all of
these circular words about like River to
the Sea what's happening that doesn't
make any sense while people are being
killed everying single day we have a
tragedy a genocide a holocaust happening
in Gaza and everybody is just like just
like playing their balls like what do
you think about the economy what do you
think about what do you think about Iran
that's [__] there's killing right
happening right now and we're just like
watching it and trying to fill time with
useless conversation but how do you fix
it short term though because short make
Israel stop there's no how do you do
that exactly is America has to tell
Israel stop because basically Israel is
a client State it's taking all of its
money in the states it has actually
sucked America dry with all of the money
that it's taking away from him and yet
it's not doing anything so why do you
think Biden Administration is not
telling them to stop because they are
[__] cowards because it seems that
every four years every American
president go and kiss the the hand and
bend the knees and go to APAC to make
them sure that Israel is much more
important in their foreign policy than
America itself and the only one who did
not do it was Bernie Sanders the only
Jewish American
who who refuses to go to ipac and you
cannot call that
anti-semitic right and you have to be
very very careful about being
anti-semitic or anti-jew because if you
call me anti-semitic I'm just like I'm
going to [__] you man I'm not like my my
idol is John Stewart B Sanders I voted
for him for presidency is this whole
thing about like using anti-semitic and
islamophobe and all to kind and
transphobe to shut down the conversation
it's [__] you have a murderous
country who have lied to the
International Community who have
actually neutered its own Ethiopian
women because they didn't want black
people to reproduce who kidnapped
Yemen's Jewish people from their parents
who have like countless atrocity who
have even have zoning zoning laws like
Jim Jim Crow it's like what are this
this is like a racist country that is
supported by United States and it's K
and you know it's fine there's a lot of
racist country horrible people but they
have I've never seen a country killing
30,000 people within 100 days this is 10
times the number of ukrainians being
killed in Russia in 2
years it does not make and about nuclear
weapons yes they have calculated it
right now they' have calculated the
number of of weapons that have by the
TNT they have R like three uh three
three nuclear weapons in a very very
small part so it's really about the
killing Stop The Killing and then we can
talk yeah but that's that's okay so so
that's that's that now let's not subd
let's talk more about
C stuff that doesn't make any what I'm
saying is B no I'm asking the question
to say we're we're so into deep that
that the amount of parties involved is
not as simple is Stop The Killing
because you you you know the only way
this works and I'm you know I know
you're a dieh hard president Trump fan I
know you're a big fan of his and you
know you you campaign for him and all
that stuff I've heard you getting up
there you open up for him all the time
which is beautiful love oh Trump my
favorite so let me ask you this let me
let me let me ask you this why do you
think you know sometimes you you sit
there and you
say man I can't stand that person that
person
is and then you're like [__] maybe Am I
Wrong myself maybe that guy's not as bad
as I think that guy's [__] there's no
way in the world I can say anything good
about him no way if I do God forbid if I
do right okay okay do you think
like every family you know has that one
tough guy in the family and when that
person is alive nobody does anything
stupid do you know what I'm talking
every family has it you have it I have
it we all have it right it's an uncle
it's a grandfather it's a father it's
somebody is the bully he's not the bully
it's not the bully it's the guy that
doesn't allow the bully to bully that
guy it's the guy that protect yeah it's
like the protector it's kind of like you
don't want to wake that guy up like you
know that one scene from Christopher
Watkin in a movie says you know every
once in a while the lion is sitting
there and they come and pull him and
they do this and they do that Hy are
every once in a while the lion has to
wake up and tell everybody he says
everybody knows what the lion is capable
of yes right this is why people put on
their house sign that says what there is
a vicious dog you know in the back this
house believes in the Second Amendment
whether they have a gun or not the
person that's trying to rob the house is
gonna say what I would I don't want to
go and rob a house that may have a gun
in there right so that sign avoids
conflict yes why do you think basam I
I'm so curious to know what kind of an
answer you're going to give to this why
do you think during Trump there was no
war no conflict and we were expecting to
see World War III under him why do you
think I have no idea uh and I think
because maybe Trump as much as I don't
like him he was kind of business
oriented
he said like I'm not going to how much
will that work cost me no I'm not going
to do that um so maybe that's the one
thing and that's kind of something to be
good on his behalf although I'm not a
big fan uh I have a problem with other
policies but uh yeah I don't think yeah
maybe that's the only thing that b what
me I was going to ask a question too
because Okay I uh uh on the on the
spending side it's going to cost us
money he's P this that's an interesting
perspective but okay how about how about
this one how about the fact that you
know he says hey you have a button I
have a bigger button hey you do this I
know exactly where you are right now and
I can destroy you I would much rather
not how about the fact that he put the
fear in people that wanted to bully and
take advantage of other people so nobody
did during his maybe but you also have
to remember that Co came in right in the
middle that was three years later that
was three years no that was actually two
and a half years later yeah but but you
know first two and a half still if the
co came you know that's even a bigger
opportunity I have no clear answer I
could I the only the only thing is like
oh this is going to cost this money I
don't want to spend money but you but
you know what though you're a smart guy
and a reasonable guy because for me like
if I if I were to sit there and say you
know uh uh what did Clinton do you know
I voted for Clinton freaking last time
we had a balanced budget him and N gingr
worked together right so you know what
did Reagan do Reagan and tip O'Neal
would go have beer together afterwards
as two Irish men they would fight
throughout the day but at 6:00 they're
at the bar sitting they having a drink
together right you don't have to like
the enemy or somebody that maybe
policy-wise you disagree with you may
say I don't agree with them on pro-life
pro-choice I don't agree with them on
bah blah I don't agree with them on this
but holy moly the temperature was super
low during Trump than we have today
everybody that was talking about Biden's
a sweet he's a unifier he's this he's
that dud we got like it's almost a World
War III categorically we can't say it
but there's a world going on right now
because he's supporting Israel but so
did Trump though yeah but Israel didn't
do the ACT during Trump and you know
what Trump said about Netanyahu did you
hear what Trump said about Netanyahu
right can you pull up a clip about what
Trump said about Netanyahu where Trump
said after what happened with gasam
solmani okay remember when he took out
gasam solmani who was supposed to be
like the next leader f he was the number
two guy in
Iran um he criticized Netanyahu and said
he almost didn't trust him because when
Netanyahu said he was going to be in it
with him he didn't so so the part about
Trump is he doesn't have a problem
critic wait you criticized Netanyahu
your daughter's married to Kushner what
are you doing criticizing I don't know
if that would be the same if it was like
more of a massive uh like military
operation that's because it wouldn't
happen under because like you kill
someone it kind of a repercussion kind
of Li die very quickly but this is like
an ongoing for more than 3 months so I
don't know if what how would Trump would
they are you a sports guy yeah what do
you like what sport basketball you like
basketball yeah you know what they say
you know like uh uh uh sometimes like
these teams like you know Baltimore
Ravens or some of the teams like even
back in the days I don't know if you're
a Detroit Pistons guy or if you're an
old school basketball guy or not a lot
of the guys won because their defense
was sick right they just had a sick
defense or you wouldn't come through the
middle or they just were freaking
hovering all over it so annoying yeah
like like the Jordan rules and pistons
that's right the Jordan rules Pistons
right so you know sometimes you know the
the best way to prevent a war is to have
the fear you impose on everybody else
where you you know defense where it's
like you know what we're just not even
going to get there I don't even want to
do anything under this guy do you think
at this point like for example case
studies you've been here since 2014
right November 11 2014 so do you think
10 years you've been here 10 years I
came here November 28th 1990 okay and
you come here like okay uh senior Bush
senior all right Clinton huh interesting
okay boom Junior GW interesting okay
Obama huh there's a trump huh there's so
now you got so many case studies and
then in life you sit there and you say
socially these are the issues that
matter to me the most right right you
know if you and I were to start a
country together if you and I started a
country together and we got 10 million
people okay and we have an opportunity
to attract another 10 million people to
our country what do you think the
mothers and the fathers number one
priority is to come to a new country do
you think it's Social Security no do you
think it's Medicare no do you think it
what do you think is number one I would
say the SW word right security and
safety let's just say Okay a woman wants
to feel safe around a man a woman wants
to feel secure around a man right if the
number one
word is the sward especially the last
three years do you think a lot of people
in the last three years are sitting
there rep prioritizing their top reason
to elect the president somebody that's
going to lower the temperature to not
have War do you think America's kind of
there today after all the mess we've
seen the last three years I still have
hope in America I still I still like
this country this mon I consider this as
my own country I find it like I found a
second chance when I left the Middle
East I think America is actually a great
country it has a lot of potential and it
has given a lot of people including me a
second chance so I I believe in the idea
of America and the fact that I criticize
America I criticize it like like we do
we criticize it out of love in or be
better of course and um what I'm worried
about is like over the years American
might have lost that kind of lure
because it is been dragged more and more
by my military industry complex and the
money has been prioritized in order to
spend money on war spend money on the
military and I think it's I mean 68% of
your budget is taken to the military and
that's not a lot of that's that's huge
and many of these military contract has
been um exaggerated in 60 minutes just
shows something something that used to
cost $30 now cost $3,000 and there's no
catch there's there there's no curb of
these prices because they are the one
who are making up the prices so yes the
security is great and all but Security
in itself because North Korea has
security right it's not about the
security this is education and there is
and there and uh and the equality and
people let me answer this hang on one
second Mr Cuomo we're on a podcast why
are you calling us we're in the middle
of a podcast name dropping yeah I mean
Chris what are you talking about I'm
doing a live podcast with this uh
legendary comedian basam ysep and we're
having a very friendly conversation
about
you know how his honestly I'm a little
confused because he's here campaigning
on behalf of trump and we're listening
to him and I'm I'm not convinced I'm I'm
just not
convinced why does he not have a a red
hat on no he has the shirt on he's not
wearing hat he has Maga shoes on he's
got Maga shoes on and magga shirt on no
but Chris I'm gonna call you afterwards
we're on the live podcast I'll call you
right after this do your thing my man
bye hold on my phone so but going back
but going back going back to with John
Stewart on the line you're funny yeah
I'm here with BOS we best friends hold
on
Elon but but but the the reason why I'm
asking this question is because you know
when you're you're young your dad's
kicking your ass challenging you all
this stuff and you know what look at
Joey's Dad they smoke weed together I
wish my dad would smoke weed with me
look at Bobby's Dad they have drinks to
get I wish my look at I and later on
you're like dude I am so freaking glad
that guy was tough on
me thank you yeah you know what I'm
saying thank you for this so for me I'm
sitting there you know thinking like a
lot of people are sitting around saying
well look what what is the most
important you know issue for us to sit
there and resolve I think the last three
years people are sitting there saying
look man we already went through Co that
was nasty it divided America I think Co
at least 9/11 we went like this I think
Co we went like this I think maybe you
agree with that we went way like this
your team V you're team a you're this
I'm team you do no no way you team mask
shut down it was all like like so
divided right I think Americans are
tired they're tired of the fights with
the family and the relatives and we have
to hate each other and all this other
stuff we can disagree on four different
policies but guess what man I think
America is the greatest country in the
world still I think it's the greatest
country in the world does it have a
history of some of the stuff they've
done with economic Hitman yeah it's it's
documented did Eisenhower tell us be
careful with this military industrial
complex of course do you know how many
military contractors we had not
contractors where they sold products and
supplies military uh like like General
Dynamics and Boeing and all these
companies you know how many of these we
had 40 years ago 50 plus companies you
know how many it is today five the five
bought the other 45 wow so there used to
be so much competition now it's come
like this a monopoly it it's becom in
almost a form of a
nationalization because politicians are
getting so much check from them the
lobbying amount of money they're
spending so they're like hey man we'll
start a war of course yeah we should
kill and bomb Iran Nikki Haley she sat
on the board of boing and no wonder you
want another War because these people
want another War because they're going
to get another contract that promise was
made by Eisenhower as a Republican
president that said be careful with this
where these guys GNA want to go to war
all I'm saying is I think what this
election has done this last three years
I think whether your left right center I
think the most popular thought on every
woman man father
husband um you know mother wife is guys
I just want want to be safe mhm I I I
just want us to be safe and I think
that's at the top of the Mind of a lot
of people and I am so like I'm so
curious as a businessman who likes case
studies to see how America is going to
react to Afghanistan Ukraine Russia
Israel Palestine potentially China taian
I am so curious to know how they're
going to react to the election this year
so curious It's Going to Be Wild because
because I think that's at the top of
their mind I think that's at the top of
their mind Boston what do you think
well I uh I want to get it back a little
bit because since we were talking about
Palestine and Israel I think the the the
most danger thing when you talk about
this is you either called a terrorist or
anti-semitic and whatever right and
people I we see the people who are the
very pro-israel who really supported
Israel and 7th of October many of them
are actually anti-semitic especially
right-wing politicians Med Gates
and U mtj and all of those people those
people they love Israel but they hate
the Jews they are anti-semite it is very
obvious and this is why you see this the
dichotomy about how the Jewish voices
for peace these are Jewish people in New
York they come in and they take over the
Central Station and they're all Jewish
and they say not in my name the whole
idea is conflating Israel and with
Judaism is wrong and I think the most
dangerous thing that can happen to the
Jewish people of the world is to have
Israel as their representative because a
lot of Jewish people don't like them to
be their representatives as many as many
Muslims don't like some of those Islamic
regimes representing them this whole
idea of making it's all or none no
Israel have actually done a lot of
criminal activities that a lot of Jews
do not agree upon and a lot of the
people who go out in New York in
Brooklyn in Los Angeles these are Jewish
people shouting not in my name many of
those people are actually um Holocaust
Survivors D Gabor who is like a very
famous Hol Holocaust himself and he say
Israel is a Zionist terrorist aparti
country so if you think like I'm saying
this because of my Muslim or Arab
background listen to the other Jews
they're saying that Israel is the
criminal here and it's been supported
Time and Time and Time Again by the EU
by American by American Administration
I'm not asking for anything that is out
of the B I'm asking them to stop the
killing because let's say 7th of October
worst day ever okay how many people are
you going to continue to kill in order
to get your revenge because it seems
that you will not be able to eradicate
Hass as a matter of fact you can kill
100,000 people today what you have
created is 100,000 Hamas killer now this
has never it it Israel tried it before
2004 and it failed 2006 and failed 2009
and failed 2012 2014 and every time
Israel came in and they killed many
people as possible and they they came
back the solution for this is not more
killing more War I know people like like
War solves everything you will not be
able to solve everything with four the
whole idea about this is to Justice if
there's land to be given back give back
the land if there is agreement to be
done do the agreement and sit together
because believe me whatever cost you
think is too high give me up land it
will not come close to the cost of human
lives that we are losing every life
whether on the Jewish side or the or the
Muslim side or the Israeli side or the
Arab side so how do you get rid of
Hamas get rid of the reasons that
created Hamas which is what the horrible
living conditions the uh the blockade
putting people in prison not allowing
people to get their own destiny if you
do that in any more you listen Israel
could have found been founded in Uganda
which by the way the British government
gave the Jews 8,000 acres and then they
said no to 1903 if Israel want to go
Uganda you can have Uganda Hamas if you
make people and put them in the lands of
other people there already 2 million
people that already there and then you
just push them around you will have
resistance right and the thing is Hamas
wasn't there since 1984 Hames was
created 1987 until 1987 Israel killed
100,000 Palestinians since 1948 it's not
about the PLO because Israel took took
is 1948 the PLO was created 1964 these
are all a result of what Israel has been
doing wh why do you mention Uganda
because the British proposed that the
Jews should move to Africa and Uganda
pull up Uganda on a map just so we're
clear what does that have to do with
anything what I'm saying is is before
the the Israeli were pull were the
Jews were transported to Palestine you
know right right after that whole you
know World War 2 Holocaust genocide
thing that no no no before before before
yeah yeah before during that time no no
no before before I'm talking about 1882
mhm when the Zionist movement started
exactly 1882 at that time there were
only 3% of Jews living in Palestine and
they were like different they were like
they said Argentina they said Chile
Madagascar South Africa and Uganda in
19103 uh the British government
offered the the Jewish people about 80
acre 880,000 acres in Uganda mhm and and
uh they said no and the reason that they
said no so there's what you don't know
there was like a big this very
interesting there was a big conflict
between the rabbis and the secular uh
Jewish movement so the rabbis said like
we cannot go the rabbis were the one who
actually uh the objected said we cannot
go to Palestine like what do you know
what do you mean it's the promised land
it's like yes it's the promised land
when the real Jesus comes so the secular
said well maybe we should go to
Palestine and that will invite Jesus to
come it was like a whole by the way this
is all in Tudor
heral uh Memoirs you can read about that
and even
1903 Tudor herel in page 96 in the
pamphlet for the Jewish State he
said maybe the Jewish people should just
get what they can so what I'm saying is
these were discussions in the end of the
19th century and the 20th century and
then the there's like a the movement
that wanted to put the uh Palestinian
sorry the Jewish people in in Israel
actually won and it happened very very
very very slowly by
1914 there were about 7% of Jewish
people in Palestine now when the bill
for declaration happened when the bill
for declaration happened the only one
who uh rejected the B for Declaration of
like putting Jews in Palestine was a
Jewish British business businessman in
the Parliament and said like those
people are British people and we should
not put them into another place I'm not
giving you I'm just giving you the
historical you're giving us the history
I appreciate it I get it but I doubt the
Jews were like yo Uganda let's do it no
they wanted Israel but what you do you
do I'm I'm I'm sorry I I will have I
I'll have to I'll have to disagree with
you sir because you understand many of
those Jews they came from Pilgrims from
Ukraine and from Russia yeah and then
when they went to London they were
really treated bad and they were called
the problem the problem we need the
solution we need the solution this is
why when Hitler came to power he said we
need the final solution so you
understand all of these um problems
happened between the Jews coming from
Eastern Europe yeah when they went to
England and Western Europe so basically
the basic the the British people didn't
like them and they want to push them off
so the we all by the way I mean we can
joke about that but seriously the whole
thing about Madagascar South Africa
Chile and Argentina and Uganda these
were real discussions with real budgets
I'm I'm very familiar with the Zionist
movement I get it and then at a certain
time so 1914 uh 7% and then the bill for
declaration and then the first world war
nothing happened second world war with
the Nazis were like being kicking and
killing everybody and then they started
to go in mass in Palestine but are you
sensing a common theme here they go to a
country they have success let's kill
them they go to a country let's they
have success let's kill him they started
in Egypt they went to Spain they went to
Morocco they went to Europe they went to
PO in Russia can I speak can I speak let
ask question not accurate this course
this is accurate sir this is not
accurate what's not accurate of what I
just said the whole reason that I say
that is that they've been running around
the entire world it's called the Jewish
diaspora I'm speaking I'll let you speak
you could speak for a half hour I'm
asking you a two-minute question the
there's a Jewish diaspora there are
running all over the world it culminates
in the Bolshevik Revolution Zionism it
starts Theodor hers Soul it ends in the
final solution in Germany the Jewish
people said listen we just need a state
you look at the map of the Middle East
it's as big as this room we have a
little tiny microphone and we're
fighting over the size of this
microphone when you have the entire room
right here so tell me what should Israel
do now does Israel have a right to exist
and defend itself or no so can I answer
I answer yeah go ahead so first of all
certain things that you said in in that
monologue was a little bit inaccurate
yes they were treated badly in Europe
they were treated badly everywhere and
they would not treated badly in in Spain
because there that was under the the
Arab rules as matter of course they were
what do you me it was called the Spanish
Inquisition look s s sir the Spanish
inquisitions was done by the Christians
against Muslims and Jews together okay
Muslims and Jews were sitting what it
happened is what I'm saying what I'm
saying is before that panish Inquisition
Jews lived in the courts as Minister and
spits and scientist under the Arab rule
in Andalusia when the Spanish
Inquisition came in they killed both
Jews and both Muslims so well the
Crusades we all know how that story goes
between Christians and Muslims for
decades and centuries do you understand
that the first crusade did not kill a
single muslim okay but the third and the
fourth and the fifth one did what what
happened with the first crusade
enlighten me what tell the First Crusade
came out from England and they killed
2,000 Jews in Europe they didn't even
make it to Jerusalem this is how bad the
Jews were treated by the Christian
Europeans and as a matter of fact EUR
Jews did not find Refuge unless they
found it in the Arab countries I'm not
saying that they were perfect but if you
compareed what the Jews were enduring in
Ukraine and Russia and in Western Europe
and how they lived in Baghdad and Egypt
and Morocco they were a much better but
this validates the whole point of why
the Jews need Israel because every
country they go to they're going to be
run out of town or killed at the very
least they have their own country so
they could say at least we have safety
here every country every St St that you
just mentioned B is them being killed by
somebody whether it's the Christians
whether it's the Brits whether it's the
ukrainians whether it's the Russians the
whole point of Israel is like we can no
longer just just rely on other people's
niceties and empathy to not be murdered
so now we need a state of our own let me
you understand that let I understand let
me continue so all through these years
they were living peacefully relatively
under the Arab Rule and then what
happened the programs in Russia and
ukine push them to England then England
said we cannot take them anymore push
them more to the Arabs at the time at
the time Jewish people in the Arab
especially Egypt were living I mean the
first people who actually did the cinema
and the theater were Jewish Egyptian
people who lived their older lives
Jewish Christians and Muslims were
living right now the department store
like our version of Macy's and Target
they all have Jewish names because they
have part of the fabric of the Egyptian
Society for decades way before the Jews
from from Europe came MH now when the
Jews from the Europe came there's two
ways to come you can come easily or you
can come by force they started to come
with all of these shipes ships and then
you have the hagana and you have all of
the Zionist um um um gangs who started
to come into uh Palestine and they
started to there were like 1.5 million
Palestinians that you cannot erase so
the fact that they there this the AR
board you can go anywhere no because
this is their country so they went in
they replaced them and then we had the
1948 and the rest of history now having
said that do I want Israel to be erased
and I want people to go back to Europe I
will never use that kind of of argument
unless that you tell me well why don't
the Palestinians go to Arab countries if
you don't use that I'm not going to use
that I believe that Israel is a is a
matter of fact and I think it's too late
to come and erase or uh get get people
out whatever what we have to do either a
one-state solution that everybody
Palestinian and Israeli have exactly the
same equal right and all of them have
the same passport and they live in peace
and the other reason is a two-state
solution obviously so far Netanyahu and
other Israeli uh officials have said
many many many many times there will
never be a Palestinian State not in the
West Bank not in Gaza ever and these are
official uh statements by them so they
have already said that
you you sometimes people accuse Arabs
but we do not want the state of Israel
they say we don't want an state for
Palestine so you have this as long as
you think that this is your land only
and those Palestinians are indispensable
and they can go other places you will
never have peace they've had the Oslo
records they've had the abraam records
at what point does Israel say I can't
negotiate with these people hamas's CH
charting a founding Charter says we call
for the destruction of Israel in order
to make peace or to make make a deal you
need to have someone on the other side
that is willing to at least come to the
table the closest that come was yaser
arat the PLO under Clinton 1998 he came
back he they they gave him 98% of what
he wanted he came back they said no what
Israel or listen Israel is just like
America it's a democracy in a democracy
you have a free exchange of ideas the
Marjorie Taylor greens that you
mentioned are wildly different from the
aoc's it but policy is different from
rhetoric the policy of the PLO of Hamas
of fata is essentially destroy Israel
there's no two State solution the
rhetoric ham is different from fat fat
is from The Authority because there's
nothing in the charter of of fat or the
or the the point that I'm getting at is
all these political factions no one
wants come to come to the table do a
deal and here's what's happening
because they're getting worse and worse
worse they gave them 98% of what they
want have you seen they had a good hand
a few decades ago now they have no hand
you have no leverage now that's the
problem sir have you seen the video by
Netanyahu who's bragging about spoiling
the the oso Accord on his own I've seen
the video yeah he said like like I'm
going to destroy it we're going to hit
them nobody's going to do that anyway
this is the guy and by the way just a
little bit of think the oo Accord you
know it was signed by y from one side
and from Isaac Rabin from
what happened to is he got assassinated
by aw by a Jew by by by a far right
radical Jew he was a moderate who who
who who uh was a part of what part
that's that's Jew what kind of
organization was he part of he was on
the far right party where organization
where Ben gair the head of the National
Security Now is AD Minister NY yeah news
flash every country that democracy has a
left left wing and a right wing I but I
don't think every country has at least
two terrorist people as ministers
because Ben gair was arrested on the
account of killing isak Rabin as a
matter of fact there's a very famous
video for him where he got the emblem of
his car two months before ISAC Rabin
like we've got your car next we got you
two months later ISAC Rabin this is the
kind of government that you are
defending it is a terrorist government
that kill its own people even balim who
is the Minister of Finance he was
arrested because he was was going there
by 600 lers of gasoline to blow up an
Israeli Highway this is the kind of
criminals who kill people gaing
everywhere and I I find it very
difficult that to find somebody actually
like to defense actions so are you
saying that Israel is the only country
in the Middle East that has a thug like
regime oh no not at all but okay so this
is pretty common for that neighborhood
but you know what's the difference I
don't see any other country in the in
the regime saying I'm a democratic
secular country and I have Western
values well according to the world index
World economic index Israel is the only
democracy in the Middle East this isn't
our opinion exactly only democracy would
would have terrorist people in the
government which I find it very interest
here's the problem that I'm having with
you is that I actually problem with me
no with your argument with me well
you've already called me racist if I'm a
very nice person I think you are a nice
person I'm very nice I think you're nice
I never called you racist I I called
your argument M multiple times but it's
all good he said undertone he didn't
call I said that racist undertone thank
you so much it's a racist undertone
thank you bosome if you look at the chat
you're probably the nicest to me today
so we're cool so the problem that I have
with you is that either you're um
anti-israel or you're just
intellectually lazy hear me out every
problem that's a very nice insult thank
you very
much insulting me very soft I am I am I
am cuz because I believe in having
discussion and being forthright rather
than when you leave I'll be like [__]
that guy I actually think you're a smart
guy I actually think you know your stuff
you're just so fixated that Israel's the
problem the problem in the Middle East
like I said follow the money the
countries that are succeeding the
qataris even the Saudis these days
they're coming into the modern world
they're leaving the the sixth Century
mentality behind and say let's get into
the 21st century where where they need
to succeed in whether it's Gaza or
whether it's Lebanon or whether it's
Syria or whether Afghanistan they need
to focus on GDP not gdt gross domestic
product not gross domestic terrorism and
the problem is they're obsessed put the
guns down put the Quran down actually
start living by the words that the Quran
says not some false uh equivalent of
what they think is actually going on
there you talk about the genocide in
Israel or in Gaza as if it's just a
matter of fact well let me let me let me
show some stats for you because after
you see these stats Israel's the worst
genocid ever the numbers the according
to the world data if you trust data
between 1990 and 2022 the Palestinian
population overall went from 2 million
to 5 million okay pretty bad at genocide
if that's what's happening right there
in Gaza it went from 645,000 to 2.1
million it's 3x that ain't genocide to
me now to 20,000 people 30,000 people
needlessly killed during this [__]
war that was started by
is that horrible 1 million per and any
Jew or any Israeli give me that number
again 600,000 to what 645,000 to 2.1
million from from to this is in 1990 to
2022 do you know why they increased cuz
they're having babies like crazy no you
see this is how in how how like when you
watch data while being uninformed makes
me look makes you look very stupid tell
me why tell me how tell me how the
population has gone from 2 million to 5
million yeah because most of the 1.5
extra million didn't come from from Gaza
they were pushed away from other parts
of Israel so most of these people they
have increased because of refuges being
if you're talking about the settlers
those are tens of thousands stop talking
about AR millions of
people my wife family is not from Gaza
and yet they found themselves in Gaza
because they were sitting in other other
cities and Villages outside Gaza this is
the systemic pushing of people from
other parts of Israel pushing them
that's not millions of people this is
why I said that you're intellectually
dishonest we're intellectually lazy
that's not the cause of millions of
people I'm I'm I'm familiar with the
settler stuff and the disengagement 200
what you're talking about these are
people that millions of people okay the
people who belong to Gaza are 700,000
people right now Gaza is 2.2 million
that is not birth rate my friend these
are people pushed from and by the way
that's not the first time
1948 at the night of the Declaration of
the state of Israel 1.5 million 1.5
million Palestinians were like moved
overnight so it's not the first thing so
before you tell giving me numbers to you
want to appear smart know what are
behind the numbers because these are not
people like Gan babies these are people
being pushed from other places in order
to be part of the open air prison that
it is okay so then so it's not if you
want to fact check me let me fact check
you anytime that there's numbers
increasing bosev going from 650 450
whatever you want to call it to 2
million however it happens that's the
exact opposite of a genocide so the
whole genocide the whole open air prison
are talking points are talking points of
BS and this is why I said you either
intellectually lazy or you just hate
Israel basically just you dis this whole
thing about you hate Israel and hate
Islam this is a very lazy way to talk to
people kind of like your kind of like
your thing what what did I tell you that
is so lazy what did I tell you like
you're [__] racist because I'm you've
already said that multiple times I
didn't say MTI you undertone is racist
so not not me but what's going on inside
of me like you the way that you analyze
numbers is very lazy because again
really when I actually use stats and
data from
most these are numbers that were outside
said no stats you give a [__] that
California has increased triple or the
SI like people in Texas increase because
of birth rate no they increased because
people from California started moving
voluntarily you have pushed 1.5 million
people outside of Gaza inside of Gaza in
a matter of 12 years and that's why the
number has inflated it's not because
they were giving birth rate were they
were evacu where this alleged genocide
that's happening right now under your
eyes so as of as of 3 months ago there
was no genocide so it's just a new thing
well we didn't actually use the word
genocide before 3 months ago okay but
you've been calling for the river for
the sea we for decades well well also
also Israel have a lot of maps that is
putting in the greater Israel from the n
and the Euphrates that's that genocide
for five countries there and this is not
by people in the street or people
YouTube these are ministers these are
officials in the official government of
Netanyahu if you have someone an Arab
presid like the Egyptian president or
the Jordanian King tells you from the
river and the Sea it's like oh it's the
Arab authorities you are basically
complaining people on Facebook and the
official uh view point of the Israeli
government you're basically comparing
apples to oranges it doesn't make any
sense you're basically comparing
activists with people with power with
money and with weapons so I don't know
how come you're comparing them what's
your solution cuz you got all these
answers and we have no Solutions what's
your solution Justice stop killing
people and and give them back their land
that's it okay and and giving them back
the land that is going to be a much more
complicating thing who's going to lead
your negotiations Mahmud Abbas 88 years
old I have no idea man I have no idea
that's the point is you don't have an
idea well I'm I'm I'm when I say I have
no idea I'm being humble because there's
a million people who can do it but like
I'm not a politicians I'm a comedian I
come here to tell some of my opinions
but the thing is you want to put me and
and you use that and you give me I'm
sorry to say butchered political
information and num that are really
butchered politic but but it's
interesting how you have all the
solutions for Israel but you have no
solutions for Gaza or Hamas very
interesting very interesting how you can
critique everything that's going on in
Israel yes they do have some things they
need to rectify just like the United
States just like any democracy you've
got all the answers there BOS when I
said what do they do over here in Gaza
what do they do I have no idea I'm just
a comedian don't listen to me so which
one is it you either know your [__] or
you're actually so what was your
question what's the solution for is the
land for Gaza how about you stop the
killing and then we can talk okay so
let's say we do that I I here's what I
believe I need I think we need to demil
demilitarize Gaza we need to Der
radicalize because they're the leading
going to D how you do that well maybe
let's stop let's stop Summer Schools
where they teach about Jihad and they
start playing football and soccer how
about the religious schools in Israel
that actually tell people that we should
kill all Arabs and these videos you know
all those Jews that are running around
bombing everywhere around the world no
it doesn't [__] exist it's only in
Islam really but what about the Jews
killing the Palestinians inside I'm
talking about the around the world if I
said we're bad people oh we bad people
take us out that's what I'm saying no no
we very are a terrorist religion we are
a terrorist religion take us out you
said it your words you said it yeah
let's do it I mean like this is like you
have you have a really interesting
outlook for people who look like me you
look at me and I'm Muslim and you you
have all of these assumptions about me
being a terrorist while is not the
terorist you said the word I you know
what's the difference between ISL
terrorist they go on on like some Rogue
groups and they kill and they do shitty
stuff but you have like a whole country
with a whole military Arsenal who is
committing terrorism every single day
back up by there is there's your Israel
talking I'm going to talk it I'm that's
my opinion that's my opinion totally my
opinion totally cool it's all good but
you're trying to tell me that Islam
doesn't have a terrorist problem Islam
Muslims have a terrorist problem correct
it's like when you say Islam has a
Muslim problem when you say Judaism has
a Muslim problem all right a lot of
Muslims are [__] and they're doing
horrible stuff and I I do not feel the
need to defend those people because
those people don't represent me the
thing is if Jews were running around all
over the world blowing themselves up as
suicide bombers as a Jew I'd be like
guys what the [__] are we doing here
what are we doing here this is
accomplishing nothing but here the the
reality Jews aren't doing that and
Christians aren't doing that Jews are
not me ask they're not doing that
they're not doing that in the you talk
about is Gaza I'm talking about the
world happen now you're so obsessed with
this one topic I'm trying to Liv because
my family lives there my family is in
Israel really so only your family counts
my family doesn't count no no no okay
but like did your family are Liv in an
open air prison and being killed every
day the open air prison the genocide see
how new talking open only Israel left
Gaza in 2006 it didn't leave it left and
it put another blockade it's called the
disengagement why do they have a
blockade maybe because they're shooting
missiles hundreds of times a day yeah
I'd pretty much M country in a blockade
if they were shooting Miss cut a cut
them from the sea cut them from the
water and like okay go live how do you
do that let's move on from Israel
because I know you're hyper obsessed
with it why I'm not hyper obsessed you
keep asking me about Israel no I ask you
about the world and I'm asking you about
Christianity and Muslims and Judaism you
want to focus on Israel why can Muslims
move to any Christian country they want
but Christians and Jews can move to zero
Muslim countries why is
that what about Dubai what about I'll
ask it again what about all of these
count what what are you talking about
mean you're just mentioning Qatar and
Dubai and all there like of exps living
there so the middle this is my point and
I'm glad you're catching on yeah that
I'm not racist I'm I'm pointing out well
there are Christian countries who like
like [__] I wouldn't l l that because of
the economy I'm pointing out that in
certain Muslim countries they're getting
it right or at least attempting to good
for them okay yeah yes good for them
good for Qatar good for UAE good for
Saudi and what NBS is doing good for for
them they're examples of what could be
done Gaza if they took the billions of
government of of international Aid could
be Dubai but they decided to make a
terror state so the question that I'm
asking you are you saying that there's
so many money coming in and just like
Hamas used it in order to make weapons
there's people of Hamas who are literal
billionaires Living in Qatar flying
around on private jets how do you
explain that they're horrible people and
I don't condone them all right I'm
talking about the millions of people all
horrible Hamas let's let's not talk
about that we'll move on but Israel
let's let let me give you a
dissertation you you I'm trying to give
you just like shouting over me make
because every time I'm talking you are
basically going around all of the stuff
that's happening with Muslim uh people
that is bad and then you Bas what you're
doing is you under toning you are trying
to find an excuse to keep that killing
and Gaza continue because because
Muslims are bad Muslims are terrorists
Muslims are poor so let's just like kill
those people in Gaza this exct
intellectually lazy it's it's comical
because I'm not even talking about Gaza
you keep insulting
me like you are you are a [__]
racist you know like how would you what
I said that's racist I'm saying that you
say about racist the way that you speak
about Muslims that we are terrorists and
we are horrible people basically you're
telling people that we deserve to to die
and Israel has everything to do in order
to kill those people so anyways if zero
of those words hopefully putting all
those words
my wife cousin who's a doctor get killed
tomorrow I'm going to send you a
postcard so if my actual cousin gets
killed in Israel that's okay they will
not because you know what they are safe
because he's not living in an open air
prison oh why are they safe maybe
because they have the Israeli Defense
Force the Iron Dome that stops all the
Miss they don't have that yeah they
don't have that maybe you should have
built that instead of with what with all
the billions of foreign aid that what
what billion foreign aid are you these
how much money does Iran give how much
money does Qatar how much do
International Community trickled through
through Israel you understand that
Israel is actually holding your argument
holds no weight cuz all you're doing is
defending Hamas zero argument I'm the
last one to defend Hamas by the way and
I've actually said the terrorist group
and I don't be and I'm big fan of Hamas
but I'm just giving you some facts every
single money that goes into Gaza go
through Israel as a matter of fact Biden
has a big problem with Netanyahu because
he's withholding the tax money that paid
by the Palestinian people to the
Palestinian Authority and Mino is
holding it back have you heard about
that have you read about that just two
days ago if you're reading your stuff
but you don't but the thing is Netanyahu
is holding back the tax money from the
Palestinian in West Bank and he's not
giving so funny man you're so funny say
you're saying all you I'm saying you're
saying all the money that's going to
Hamas is coming through Israel filtered
through Israel filed through Israel all
the money from Iran going right through
Israel sure that's likely all the money
from by n in 2019 the party telling them
that he is actually over overlooking the
amount of money coming from Qatar and he
is doing that in order to split the the
Palestinian Authority listen to me I'm
familiar with this I'm not disagreeing
how about you how about listen educate
yourself about that I'm not disagreeing
that Netanyahu has done some [__] up
things oh here it is okay here it is oh
my God here it is Biden is in
frustrating called told BB to solve
Palestinian tax revenue issu because
Israel is withh holding the taxes you
understand every single money your
argument right there every no that's
part of the argument every single money
transaction whether it's taxes whether
AIDS it has to go through the Israeli
government so all the money that Iran is
funding Hamas you're saying that goes
through Israel is that what you're
saying through Qatar through Israel okay
that's so false it's so flagrantly false
I want you to educate yourself more okay
I will I'll go read up on this but if
you mean to tell me that Israel is
intercepting the money that Iran is
sending to Hamas and says yeah we'll
send it to you guys believe me they're
not doing that by the way 11 transcri
it's 11:15 we're going to wrap up here's
what I will say um uh uh I'm I'm GNA be
very honest with both of you guys I mean
I'm I've been listen to both of you guys
and I love this I love this let me tell
you why the average American right now
is sitting there there's a group that
agrees with you there's a group that
agrees with you regardless of what it is
a lot was said and it was actually
pretty educated discussion for me I'm
normally not this quiet I love the fact
that I heard this conversation I loved
it I enjoyed it I appreciate you for uh
uh having uh uh it was very obvious this
is what happens basam in a future when
you're doing podcast follow the same
rule the eight hours of sleep you got
last night was very helpful it was
obviously felt I I was hang out over I
mean I'm I and there's pain in my my
back as I I'm I'm speaking out of pain I
got a guy waiting for you right now just
so can I say one thing to BOS of I don't
care how much we argue and that's fine I
would have a beer with you I would party
with you I'll go see your comedy back
whatever this guy
needs I'll give you a hand I'll I'll
give you a handy under the table if it
make you feel better it's all good I
love this conversation this is the only
way that situations can be solved it can
be uncomfortable it can be argumentative
but I'd rather sit down at the table
with people I disagree with than
completely ignore them at the end of the
day at the end of the day the heated
discussions all of this at the end of
the day is words yep words don't hurt
anybody and the thing is if it hurts you
it means that you need to check your ego
one thing I learned is that put your ego
aside so if you felt that I am attacking
you attacking it's not it's like I'm
always attacking your your argument
brother I'll give you a hug on air off
air it's never about you because there
is absolutely no point of like losing
each other and losing at other we have
come from obviously different different
background but I would rather have this
heated discussion and then S stand up
and because at the end of the day we are
all Americans we're sitting here and
hopefully we're doing that in order to
learn something that will not Happ we
totally agree we're on the same p%
appreciate you for being a good sport
appreciate you for coming out gang take
care have a great weekend if you're in
Florida if you're in South Florida
tonight you're performing and tomorrow
at yeah with that back I I have uh two
shows in Arabic tonight and three shows
in English Saturday and Sunday and
what's the location uh Miami Improv
Miami Improv go stop by and tell them
you heard them on PD maybe I'll be there
you never know come to the English show
you'll enjoy it take care everybody bye-
bye bye-bye
I have one
Ju